welcome to this video playing Hoggy
Hoggy I cannot really do it right
seagoing b6 no he's going to be 50 wow
that is supposed to be any good I don't
believe it let's see what happens going
for some central control here five
interesting i think i'm happy to block
his his bishop on b7 yeah of course he
can try something like that but going to
be interesting e six Bishop d3 is
special on g7 looks strong but I'm not
quite sure how is going to develop his
pieces the night on b8 for example yeah
but you can never ever take on d5 sf5
hangs so
I will be diff didn't expect that move
at all okay interesting I mean I should
have expected it that was my problem
that didn't expect it but interesting
maybe go here I'm not quite sure about
this but it's an it's an aggressive
continuation
yeah my I just say my argument in this
game is simply that he has no King
position and will have problems to find
a safe place for us King on eh currently
I want to go rook e1 Bishop b4 things
like that and played him 32 times it's
kind of it's a lot and so open up the
position yeah I think here one now
I mean if he goes d5 now i'm not i'm not
really willing to believe that this
should be okay with this King wide open
yeah maybe you should take on you for
one castle or something like that I mean
it looks bad but I think it's a bad
position anyway wow it does not want to
Castle we rather wants to kill the
structure and everything okay mm so I
can go Quinn d5 not sure about this but
i think i will just be annoying about
castling route d 1 92 94 just one way to
do it or you can also go for four
tactics with rookie one and try to take
only five and which is close to working
can you prepare castling i don't really
see it I mean queen f6 Queen f7 over
money form with the noid that's the end
of this story yeah night only for also
introduces and i take c 5 which is very
strong or can be very strong whoa okay
so it's going for Queen to g8 I guess
night you for Quincy aids maybe
ok
okay it's a similar idea I don't need to
hurry much yeah I think I can just play
it just like a position as no no need to
worry that I'm a pawn down here okay so
wants to do something on g2 i guess i'm
preparing queen age 3 anyway so here we
go Queen age 3 attacking h7 planning
Queen f5
okay so Queen f5 or anything else when
ticking it's probably not bad don't see
a clear win or something we now five
looks nice maybe just do this piling up
more on the deep on that that's just it
that's good right can also play rookie
to the one next I mean like it's not
really able to do much
he's entirely passive
yeah it's basically out of ideas yeah
but here i can take c5 I mean not sure
that I want but I think I'll do these
seven is under fire by rook and queen
and I've got Queenie six now also here
you can just go back and be happy with
what happened to him ok man this rook to
d1 and now I think check check we should
have 6 26 wins the house black resigns
sorry for that I have to make sure that
I close the game database ok that was an
interesting game but I'm think I'm I
think I'm kind of happy with that he
played a somewhat strange opening with
this be five well I just played yeah
simple simple stuff in developing
grabbing the center and seeing what
happens this is a an interesting
structure that is not not clear at all I
mean black has got a very strong bishop
on g7 but it's got problems with the
night on be aid I'm i don't know i don't
know it's a business structure that i
have a hard time assessing i cannot
really say that yeah that i'm positive
that white is better yeah i mean maybe
not the only thing I know is that it got
it got two very tricky in short order
this castles 97 and now I went to form
with hindsight I'm not so sure about the
move I didn't really think about it for
that much and so this is a bit of an
annoyance this move I mean
no I think this is an interesting move
I'm not sure about it probably not
something that the computer would
approve but now it's it gives me it
gives equal I mean which means that
there is some kind of compensation or it
hints at that I don't really trust the
engine like blindly if you just have it
on for three seconds back here and ya
know I took a 20 and this really feels
like good compensation I mean black
cannot go d5 he has something like
rookie one looks bad yeah yeah that's
really bad I was thinking maybe you
should take and castle this is this is
actually given by the engine and just to
slide advantage to watch this this yeah
and now I mean okay hmm it's still it's
not you I don't think you can easily
sacrifice p2 here as the B porn would be
very dangerous after that so and the
engine also gives this move it's a bit
yeah it's a bit weak but I think you
have to keep the pawn yeah something
like this this gives the engine gives a
slight edge for white well is it just
slight edge voyage surprising it really
looks good anyway I would have been
happier in that position and this is
just probably not playable right yeah
let's plus one stitch it just it's just
too much pressure you have to get to get
the King out of the middle and he never
managed okay Queens should be all I have
a of time here to centralize this is in
plus three plus four position and yeah
he's falling falling a party and check
you know the easiest tears that this and
sorry that's easy for black sort of
taken yeah I think check and just go for
the shack go for this kind of thing
being a piece up for for nothing it's
not a bad it's not a bad result okay
thanks for watching